le document que je vais vous présenter
voilà un événement qui marque un
tournant dans l'histoire de la réunion
ils concernent la période anglaise alors
la période anglaise commence en 1810
quand la france vaincue lors des combats
qui l'opposent à l'angleterre perd lise
ile-de-france de beaux bons qu'ils
étaient toutes les deux à l'ordre
françaises le 30 mai 1814 le traité de
paix est signé et la grande-bretagne
accepte de restituer certains
territoires à la france dans l'hindu
bourbon ce document intitulé l'acte de
la remise de l'île de bonbons aux
commissaires de sa majesté très
chrétienne représente la rétrocession de
lille et il date du 6 avril 1815 alors
son contenu mais en présence les deux
parties concernées d'un côté les
français avec notamment le nouveau
gouverneur de l'île roubaud bouvet de
l'osier commissaire du roi de france et
de l'autre côté les anglais dont le
secrétaire en chef du gouvernement d
ile-de-france et de bourbon un dénommé
telfair représentant du roi de grande
bretagne
il y décrit le déroulement de la
cérémonie de rétrocession
cela se passe sur la place d'armes à
saint denis où sont assemblés les
habitants est l'un des faits notables de
cette cérémonie et les changes de
pavillon le pavillon blé et baisser et
remis aux troupes anglaises et le
pavillon français est hissé aux
acclamations de vive le roi vive les
bobos chaque pavillon est saluée par 21
coups de canon chacun il y est également
indiqué que les anglais délivre les
établissements civile
militaire de lise bourbeau et les
français eux déclarent avoir pris
possession d'une part de ces mêmes
établissements et d'autre part de deal
pour hbo à la fin du document toutes les
personnes officielles présentes ont
imposé leur signature et leurs cachets
de cire
on peut voir que ces cachets sont en
assez bon état puisque l'on parvient à
distinguer le sceau de bouvet de l'osier
au final ce qu'il faut retenir c'est
qu'à la suite de cet acte l'île de
bonbons redevienne françaises et l'île
de france devenue l'île maurice brest
anglaises les îles sont séparés et
chacune poursuit son propre destin